استشهد اخوي
31 استشهد في الشيخ زايد ضرب وهو في
السياره افناه عند الاندونيسي في الشيخ
زائد بين المدرستين في كانت مقبره جماعيه
عشان مؤقت عبين ما تخلص الحرب حطيناها
هناك عند
الاندونيسي عده ايام يومين ثلاثه اسبوع
اسبوعين اللي هو خشوا علينا بي ما قدرناش
نعمل اي حاجه احنا احنا الكويسين العايشين
طلعنا شردنا على مكان اللجوء اللي هونا
عند ابو زيتون عند
المعسكر بعد اسبوع اسبوعين طولوا في الحر
والبريه تاعت لما قدرنا نروح نصل عرفنا ان
اياد موجود رحنا دورنا عليه ما لقيناه صنا
ندور ونبحك شان وهان لقينا يد اخوي بس من
بين المقبره كلها هي بس لحاله يد لقيناه
لم اجوا اليهود لم بشوا عننا في الج في
المقبره عند الشيخ زايد واخذ الجت عشان
اخوي كان مزوي شويه حطيناه في القرنه احنا
ما شافهوش الحمد لله وين المسلمين فيش
مسلمين وينهم واحد يهودي يجي يفح قبر
بالجرافه مش بد احنا احنا لما ندفن ميت
اقل من راحتنا بدفنه يجي هو في الجرافه
ينتش الجدد كلهن ولما جينا على المقبره
ندفنه كانت طريق صعبه شويه ما قدرناش نمشي
ف نحط على توك توك ولا حاجه حطيناه شويه
على توك توك ما قدر يكمل التوك توك تبعش
نزلت من التوك توك ليش نزلت من التوك توك
عشان فيش طريق الطريق مسكر
وصلنا المقبره ودفنا جنب ابن عمي الاني
محمد
[موسيقى]
اسامه